Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is Ryan.
And we are covering tales from the dark multiverse.
It's kind of surprising that DC still releasing these, but at the same time,
I'm kind of not surprised because they were just so fricking cool and it kind of
sucked. The DC stopped doing it for a time, you know, but this is a cool one.
The next one we get after this is actually flashpoint.
So I'm really excited to see what this has in store. Now,
for those of you guys who are not familiar with tales from a dark multi-verse,
a lot of you guys are familiar with like the, the dark nights metal event,
right? The idea that you have the multi-verse and DC comics.
And then on the opposite side, you have the dark multi-verse,
which is basically worlds that are not supposed to exist,
worlds that are born from like nightmares and things like that.
And so tales of the dark multiverse what's designed to build on that.
And it was designed to basically give us stories involving versions of Batman
from the dark multiverse,
just these really terrible and twisted versions of his character.
And so what this does is this initially starts out by kind of giving us the
typical origin of Batman and the way that we normally expect, right,
in the sense that you've got Bruce Wayne, who's alongside his parents,
Thomas and Martha, after seeing the, the mask of Zorro in the process,
they're basically his parents were shot to death in crime alley by judge Hill.
And then Bruce Wayne basically goes on to travel the world,
learn all kinds of different skills and then come back to Gotham as Batman.
That's the way it normally works.
The way this works is that it wasn't just Bruce Thomas and Martha.
It was also Thomas Elliot and his parents. Now,
for those of you guys who don't know who Thomas Elliot is,
Thomas Elliot made his debut in a story that was really,
really awesome called Batman hush.
But this was basically a story where hush popped up out of nowhere and
essentially just like turned all of Batman's villains or really kind of took all
his villains and pit them against Batman and even some of his allies. Right.
And it was cool stuff like Superman falls under the control of poison Ivy.
It's just these amazing ways to just kind of moving characters around and in a
way that you don't normally see, and it was literally Batman,
just running the gauntlet. It was, it was nuts. It's an amazing story.
I think it's like 12 issues long or something like that.
And so what this does is it basically tells us that in the aftermath of Bruce
Wayne's parents dying,
that the Elliotts were the one who took in Bruce instead of Alfred.
And that as time went on,
Bruce became more and more disconnected and fell deeper and deeper into madness,
right. Basically began to kind of lose his mind.
And so the result of this is that we ended up picking up some years later and
Gotham city is wholly different.
Now instead of Gotham city being one of the mini cities among the United States,
it's now a city state is independent of the United States.
Gotham has us on precedent. It's got us on defense contractors.
It really is its own country. And you have people who play different roles here,
right? The person who's in charge of Gotham's defense contracting is Jason Todd.
The attorney general of Gotham is Harvey dent. You know, the,
the founding families, the entrepreneur, and the, the philanthropist, the,
the kind of big time financial guy outside of, you know,
the one who runs Wayne enterprises is Oswald cobble pot,
but really Gotham's first family,
the richest individuals in Gotham are essentially Thomas Elliot and Talia Al
Google knows a little bit of importance that I kind of want to impress upon you
guys here. Natalia algal, as you guys know,
is the biological mother of Damian Wayne. And in the main DC universe,
it was Talia and Bruce who ended up having Damien right now,
this the means by which Damien was conceived are questionable at best.
But the idea behind this is that Talia basically procreated with Bruce.
And this instance she's with Thomas Elliot.
Now the motivation behind that will actually become a little more apparent as
time goes on in terms of why she's here. But it's one of these little,
one of these interesting things where it we're essentially Thomas Elliot is the
one who's basically running Wayne enterprises when enterprises effectively fell
to him. Now, how that happened, we'll find out here in a second.
But the funny thing about this is that the reason why Talia is currently with
Thomas Elliot is because she's still the one who runs a league of assassins that
hasn't really changed. She killed her father,
took his place as she's the one who runs the show,
but the league of assassins serves as a means by which Thomas Elliot became a
Senator, right? So using power, using information, probably money,
different things like that. They ended up securing his place as a Senator.
Now we also end up getting is that we're initially our first inclination here is
to like the wealthy and the powerful of Gotham.
We end up finding out that things are a lot more dire than they are than they
initially appear. What you have here is very much a kind of czarist society,
right?
Are bolstered revolution type of society in the sense that when you have the
bulk of the Bolshevik revolution in the early 19 hundreds in Russia,
what you had was extreme social inequality, right?
So you had the super wealthy in the form of the [inaudible] family and those
individuals they can sorted with. And then you had basically everybody else,
right, who was living in destitution in squalor.
And that's why the Bolshevik revolution happened is because you basically had
people who had just had enough and they revolted against the czars.
They killed the entire czar family, including Anastasia. And then of course,
we ended up getting Vanguard, communism,
which is a form of communism that never works.
But the idea behind this is that you basically have this extreme inequality.
So you have individuals who are revolting against the government,
and then you have the government itself,
which is kind of putting out this illusion to the general public.
Everything's fine.
And look at how great the upper class is doing and so on and so forth.
That's a familiar, we basically follow Elliot when he was called away.
And we pick up with Dr. Crane right now, Dr. Crane is normally scarecrow,
but this guy's here within Arkham asylum.
And the idea behind this is that within Arkham,
most of the traditional criminals that we're familiar with have largely just
kind of been locked away, becoming the characters that we know, for example,
Jarvis touch is not actually the mad Hatter instead.
He's just a crazy guy in a cell who sings these songs about the devil of ARCA,
right? This kind of rumor or the story about how there was at one point in time,
a force that just kind of moved around Arkham asylum.
At least it was put forward by Amadeus Arkham, right?
The guy who originally ran and established the, the asylum itself,
that it was just kind of this ghostly apparition that would move between the
walls and that kind of a thing, right. You know, it's,
it's kind of creepy and the way that it's done, but the reason why, uh,
Thomas Ellie has been called here is because Bruce Wayne has died.
And he's only the most recent in a series of deaths that have happened within
Arkham. And for the most part, it's just kind of being swept under the rug.
They can kind of be explained away, but in this instance, it can't right.
The indication here is that Bruce Wayne basically rolled over on his pillow and
suffocated himself. Right. Which is a little weird, but he's got the,
the autopsy scars and all that kind of stuff. And it's a little crazy, right?
Because Bruce Wayne is just dead.
And so what you end up getting here is this arrangement that,
that seems to have happened where you essentially had Dr. Crane working
alongside Thomas Elliot to kind of keep Bruce Wayne in a vegetative state that
Bruce Wayne had basically been essentially, you know,
a vegetable for quite some time.
Now it's not really said explicitly on the nose, like, Hey reader,
I helped Thomas Elliot keep Bruce Wayne in a vegetative state so that Thomas
Elliot could take over the Wayne fortune and keep it right because of Bruce
Wayne just woke up and word got out. You know,
even if it somehow managed to leak out that Bruce Wayne is within argument
silent and he's lucid, and then people would be like, what's going on here?
They were started asking questions, right. And it would lead to a great, big,
huge debacle. And so keeping them off the grid basically kept things silent.
The other part of this though,
is that within the hand of Bruce Wayne is a ticket to the Mark of Zorro.
And that's why things are a little wonky here because it's kind of like,
we've never really seen this before now,
following that you end up having Dr. Crane as he leaves and basically comes
across the groundsman. Who's largely alluded to be the joker,
but then suddenly the lights kick off.
And that's when you end up having this kind of, of, you know, this, this,
this rhyme, this being given by Jarvis touch, what'd,
you kind of continues on in the darkness and where the janitor is kind of like,
okay, you know, the lights will kick back on here in a second. You know,
it was cool. It happened sometimes it's super late.
We get these rolling power outages.
It's not really that uncommon that the emergency lights kick on and like this
just horrifying looking Batman besiege that looks like hush.
If you became Batman just comes flying onto a onto Dr. Crane and just
seems to kill the guy. It's kind of nuts following that,
like Thomas Elliot bales, right.
He ends up getting out of there and getting on his helicopter and flying back to
what looks to be his penthouse apartment that you have this, that man figure,
just perched kind of looking at them when that happens.
A rocket shoots out of nowhere and takes a helicopter down. And when that,
when the helicopter crash in lands, you end up finding out that, that,
that kind of lands among, you know,
we're gonna have all these rebels and so on and so forth.
But the rebels are basically led by Barbara Gordon.
And the reason why is because in the rise to Gotham becoming a city state,
that her father Jim Gordon was killed in the process. Now, again,
we're not given a whole lot of indication here.
If we just sort of use a little bit of a combination of common sense and a
little bit of, of just kind of guesswork.
We can largely assume that Gotham was any city just like any other.
And that something seems to have happened.
Gotham basically decided to become an independent city state,
somehow it was allowed. And that in turn led to commissioner Gordon,
possibly a handful of others becoming part of a resistance movement.
And in that process, Jim Gordon was killed.
Barbara took up the mantle in a stead and is basically been fighting ever since.
And so when that happens, of course,
you end up having what's more or less a Gotham city military come to sending on,
right. They kind of come to sitting on this thing,
but you also end up having Tim Drake. Who's here along with Cassandra Kane,
that these guys are more or less unified absent the idea of Batman, right.
But they're still there. And they still work as a singular group in the process,
you know, with the, the, the helicopter crash landing, you get, uh, Cassandra,
Katie get Tim Drake who basically show up here.
And then they're met by the arrival of one of the gray sons and the gray sun is
decreasing. Now it's kind of, it's kind of weird here because gray son,
there's actually a really cool concept of this character that we'll talk about
here in a second. But this guy lays waste to Tim Drake and Cassandra. I mean,
overcomes them like that. It's not even a, it's not even a fight.
It's not even a contest. And he asked him Drake, like,
do you really want to do this fight right now? Because if we do,
you're going to die. And Tim Drake is like, we'll fight, but not today.
And he basically ends up leaving. Now.
We ended up finding out that gray son and in really the gray sons themselves
seem to work,
or at least are heavily involved directly with the president of Gotham,
president Lincoln, March, which is a really interesting concept.
Given the new 52 Batman run.
The cool thing is that with the gray son being here, he's basically told,
like I was sitting here directly from the president because we need to keep an
eye on you. Right. We need to keep an eye on Gotham.
We have to keep all this stuff under control.
And it's one of the interesting things here,
because it's not the first time this has happened that other individuals out
there, right? Like attorney general Harvey dent was attacked.
The GA basically the Gotham city security force, right?
So like they're their paramilitary group. Captain flashed the ones who, uh,
the one who runs it is missing as well.
There were these clippings about the old Wayne murders that were found alongside
these individuals where at least I'm sorry, in a,
in a place where these individuals work when they went missing.
And so there's a kind of huge mystery going on here.
And that's why Thomas Elliot was secured by gray sun because it's kind of like
the powerful of Gotham are vanishing.
We're here to grab you to make sure that doesn't happen to you now, from there,
they ended up of course, capturing Barbara Gordon.
And when Grayson starts interrogating her,
is this interesting thing where you kind of find out that, Hey,
like her people did not bring down the Airship. They don't really know who did,
but then Grayson basically drops the,
the idea of like these powerful people are missing.
These news clippings are there. And then she's like, Oh,
it's the Wayne murders that a reason why those guys are going missing. Okay,
well, let's start to make a lot more sense.
Then I'm going to give you an easy clue here, right?
And this will put you back on the path of actually finding out what's going on.
What she tells him is that the Airship of Thomas Elliot was most likely shot
down by Lux Corp surface to air R I M 72 Raptor missile.
And you cannot access those in the United States. Instead,
the only way to get those is outside of the U S and the idea is that you can
only find them in Santa Prisca and that several containers of quote unquote
structured grade lumber from Santa Prisca arrived in Gotham Harbor last week.
And the person who received those is a defense contractor of Gotham.
It's Jason Todd. And so she basically pointed the finger and says,
we don't know who shot you down, but it looks like it was probably Jason Todd.
So you may want to go and investigate him. And then she's like,
as far as this assassination attempt that was made on your life,
I wouldn't really worry about that because what it looks like is you've got
much, much bigger problems. Now,
what we end up doing is transitioning to old town in Gotham city and old town is
basically the base of operations for where Jason Todd operates as the defense
contractor, of course, some pretty heavy hitters, some big henchmen.
And when they get in there, the immediate question,
the immediate interrogation from Grayson is what's going on here?
Why is it that you're receiving missiles and so on and so forth?
And when you initially have Jason Todd, who's like,
I don't really know what you're talking about. I have no idea what's going on.
Grayson basically says like, well, we can say Dick Grayson basically says, look,
I've got my drones that are going through here and there they're scanning your
entire facility. Right? And they found 12 Lux,
Corp ordinance containers containing these missiles.
And one of the missiles are gone, right? So by all standards of measurement,
this missile came from your facility and it was used,
try to shoot down a sitting, Senator, spill the beans on what's going on, right.
And literally like targets his drones on him with the intention of killing him,
following that you end up having all these forces that start showing up.
And they're actually members of the league of assassins,
which are led by Talia Al Gore.
And that's when Jason Todd starts to spill the beans and saying, sorry, man,
it's the end of the road for you. Right? Like the owls have had their time.
Right?
So this points to the idea that Dick Grayson is actually part of the court of
owls. Now the court of owls have moved beyond Gotham city and, Oh, I'm sorry.
Moved up in Gotham city on her effectively seemed to be the ones running the
show here or at the very least, or heavily involved in president Lincoln, March,
which kind of makes sense,
given his involvement with the court of owls and the events of new 52,
but with the quarter bowels,
having long been the secret of organization that worked within Gotham city
itself, that, that, that kind of concept still continues on. And so Jason,
Todd has kind of like, this is the end of the road, man.
Well then suddenly out of nowhere,
a grenade comes flying in right in like the whole place starts to burn.
And when that happens,
like you've got Thomas Elliot and you've got degrees Grayson who basically get
out of there as fast as they can.
When the Batman comes pouring in and starts tearing into everybody. Now,
forest park, Dick Grayson fights against Batman as best he can,
but he's not much of a, of a, of a competitor here. Right.
And so of course he basically ends up escaping. You've got a, you've gotten,
you know, a Batman who immediately goes after Jason, Todd and Jason Todd.
Here's the thing, man, Jason,
Todd goes down like a hero and never were like a hero.
He just goes down like the most awesome way.
Where he's like, he's like, do you really think I'll go down easy? He's like,
come on then. Right. He was like, come on big boy let's dash.
So they just start shooting. Right. It's it's the craziest thing.
Well, this thing, well, following that revelation from Jason,
Todd Thomas Elliot ends up inside of Wayne Manor goes running up on Talia and
he's like, what's going on here? Right? Like she's like, I have like,
where have you been? I have no idea what you're talking about. He's like,
I just got done talking with Jason, Tom, when all hell broke loose.
And he told me that the league of assassins is going to take me out and they're
led by you. And he did it with your blessings.
So the two of you are working together to oust me.
So what in the heck is going on here?
And her response is the league of assassins did not have any attempt on your
life, but do not misunderstand your place in the bigger picture. Thomas Elliot,
we put you where you are and we have plans for you.
We would like to put you in the position of president of Gotham,
but we also recognize that you could be killed at any point in time.
And so we've got backup plans for our backup plans and we needed Jason Todd's
resources, right.
It just happened to be that Jason Todd decided to make that move against you
right then, because he has his own ambitions, you know,
and that kind of a thing it's kind of crazy because the response of Thomas
Elliot is if you want to maintain access to my multi-billion dollar company,
then you would do well to keep me alive.
One saying that he suddenly looks on his desk and realizes there's a comic for
the Mark of Zorro. And he's like, where did you get this?
And that's when he starts freaking out.
Talia has no idea what he's talking about. Right?
She doesn't know anything about this Batman type character.
She thinks he's losing his mind. And he's like,
this Batman's guy has been in this house, right?
He's been in this house before this all started in one place.
I'm going back there and we're going to finally get answers, right?
So we ended up going back to, what's basically Wayne Manor,
the original Wayne Manor house. And when he gets in there,
he starts asking the question like, who are you? Why are you doing all this?
And he's met by this voice. And this, this voice says,
is there something I should know about the Wayne murders?
And that's what we end up finding out that Dick Grayson's here.
And the reason why he's here is he tracked down Thomas Elliot,
that he's got a bug on Thomas Elliot who could overhear what he says,
and he's got a tracker. See,
we can always know where his movements are and given the conversation he had
with Talia and given the, given his movements,
it was only a matter of logic that he would end up here. Not only that,
that were Dick Grayson is the head of president March's security.
That way you end up finding out is that president March and those guys had long
believed for quite some time that the league of assassins working alongside
Thomas Elliott and tended to move him above his station and replace president
Lincoln March. And so it was kind of like, we suspected that for a long,
long time.
And now you have basically confirmed it through your conversations with Talia,
that you plan on ousting the president and taking his place. Well,
in the middle of all that the floor comes crashing down, right?
Literally they get yanked through the floor.
And when they basically begin to come to the Thomas Elliot looks around and sees
Alfred, and he's singing this, this really creepy nursery rhyme, hush,
little baby Les, you call down the bloody bat of Gotham town.
He looks above desiring of a corpse to plant beneath the ground.
He knows your heart, your blackest deed, and follows them wherever they lead,
where you go, the bat will know and find you with the devil speed.
It's a really cool rhyme. Like I love that run, right.
And Thomas Elliot does not immediately recognize Alfred.
And this really kind of shows the fact that Thomas didn't have a whole lot of
involvement with Alfred and offered is largely been absent in the years since
Thomas took over Wayne enterprises, all that kind of stuff.
And so what you end up what you end up having happen as an Alfred basically
tells Thomas it was a mistake coming here, right? It was a terrible,
terrible mistake. And when the lights kick on, there's one, this,
this holding cell that's here, that it looks like it's intended for a,
for whoever the next victim is seemingly Thomas himself.
And then you've also got like all these other,
other individuals who are currently being held here,
Jason Todd's being held here, all these folks, right? Like, uh,
like Dr. Crane is being held here.
And that's when the bat starts to sort of pop up because Thomas asked the
question like Alfred, did you do all this? And the response of Alfred is no,
I'm just a humble, humble man. Servant. I serve the wanes nothing more.
And then he says the waves are dead Alfred. And the response of Alfred is,
are they master Thomas? Are they really dead? Indeed.
And then you end up having this Batman who shows up here right now,
Batman literally goes after Thomas and says like, I know what you did, Tommy.
Right? All those years ago, your family driver,
what you promised him to kill your own parents and how it all went wrong.
Who else? And Thomas, like, who are you? He's like, who else would I be?
Everyone's dead. But us, the Wayne's are dead in that alley.
The Elliotts were killed on the road. A few years later,
the driver was killed in a cell awaiting trial for another crime.
Even the decent cop who took the call, Jim Gordon is death. And he says,
when your parents took me in, your mother said,
the boys will finally get to be real brothers. How Dr. Crean laughed.
When I told him that story,
the idea that I was ever like a brother to you who took every single thing from
me, this is Bruce Wayne, right?
Like Thomas has worked against Bruce from the beginning, right?
The Thomas seemed to have wanted to take his fat ticket's parents out and then
to take out the parents of,
of Bruce and take over the Wayne fortune for himself. And,
and the response to Thomas is you're dead. I saw you die.
You were on the operating table. You had an autopsy done on you.
You had the autopsy scars. And that's when he says, no,
this was all planned from the very beginning.
You were not the only visitor in Arkham, Tommy. Right?
Alfred was always with me. And he says,
so where's the handyman that we planted at Arkham Jack Napier.
This is the guy who gave me the surgical scars that made it look like I had an
autopsy, right? So I could basically take my death and escape that place.
He gave me the drugs so I could look like I died. He says with Alfred's help.
I learned what happened to my parents years ago and Navy,
or got me access to people in Arkham who could help me avenge them.
All these individuals who were held within Arkham, asylum, Amadeus,
himself who taught criminal psychology, the dispraise spy, Nick Mason,
who taught him to sky's. Lockpicking all things by craft.
All of these individuals played a role in Bruce Wayne becoming who he was
becoming this version of Batman,
that's dark and twisted and knowing how to kill people with surgical precision
and disappear without ever being caught.
And so you initially have Thomas who begs, right? He's like, no, no, no, no.
You misunderstand. You misunderstand, right? We're we're brothers, man.
And together we can fix everything. We can fix Gotham.
We can make it a better place, man.
We can make it better than what it used to be. And the response is, no,
that's not going to happen. You're never going to see the light of day again.
Right. This is it you're finished. And so from there,
you switch back over to kind of like the, the Gotham state media, right.
Which is kind of going through and saying, Hey, like, you know, here's,
here's everything that's going on. You know? And that, you know, with the,
the vanishing of Thomas Elliot,
the Wayne fortune has passed on to Alfred pennyworth who was a family Butler,
but nobody's seen him in years.
So we have no idea where this billionaire is or what it is that he has going on.
That Talia algal is now on the arm of president Lincoln, March. Right.
She's with him now, you know, many of us thought Talia would see God,
the affections of Jason Todd, but he's gone. And it seems like it's pretty fast,
right?
She just immediately jumped after the vanishing of Thomas Elliott directly into
the arms of Lincoln March. Right. So I program me and it's just kind of like,
this is pretty wild, right? Like it's pretty crazy stuff.
It's interesting because what you end up finding out here is the handyman is the
one who basically kind of guards all these cells. So basically the,
the joker of sorts that Alfred is just kind of,
they're keeping the place cleaned up as trashed as it is.
And that basically Batman, the silence,
which is what he's called now is traveling throughout Gotham and killing all
this, all the higher powered guys,
all the folks who are running the show and who are completely and totally
corrupted, what the end goal is. We have no clue.
We have no clue if he wants to just distill madness throughout the entirety of
the city. But whatever it is, this is an effect. A version of Bruce Wayne,
who's experienced torment, who was broken by madness,
who completely and totally lost his mind in the face of the fact that he had
completely lost everything with that being said,
we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you guys are new here to come as explain mission,
you guys are the sub button to become part of the Rob poor.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a light and.
Your wallet or purse.